hello i'm darren pemberton
deputy leader of stratfor navy district
council and lead member for planning
policy
we are consulting on a site allocations
plan and one of the specific proposals
in chapter seven
proposal rural four at me unveil known
locally as me and vale woodland
has already arised considerable public
interest
so i just wanted to take the opportunity
to set out while we are consulting on
this proposal
with a little of the history of the
wider site
the site is part of the wider me and
vale community being developed on the
former long marston engineer resources
depot
in planning terms it was accepted some
time ago as a previously developed or
brownfield
site the wider depot site is included
within
development policy as11
large rural brownfield sites
of the stratford-upon-avon core strategy
adopted in 2016.
this definition for the site is entirely
consistent with the government's
own definition of brownfield land set
out in the national planning policy
framework or
mppf the original plans for the
moonville community
also included development on part of the
me and vale woodland site in question
as part of a leisure park that
ultimately has never come forward
this site was also consulted on last
year in an earlier version of the site
allocations plan
as a reserve housing site it is no
longer needed for that purpose
but it is important to define its future
in planning terms
and has now been included as a
standalone allocation
because of this we feel that it is vital
to consult the public
at this draft stage as to whether the
proposal ruled or for
me and val woodland is appropriate and
should be brought forward
in terms of the proposal that is the
subject of the consultation
it would result in development of part
of the existing plantation woodland
the proposal explicitly acknowledges
this and seeks to balance the loss of
trees by retaining the mature trees
strengthening biodiversity across the
site
and maintaining and enhancing public
access
the figure of 300 homes specified is set
out as an absolute maximum
any development will also need to ensure
that it does not undermine the
operations of the adjacent
rail technology center which we are
seeking to safeguard for inward
investment
as the home of zero carbon train
development
under proposal rural three
the proposal also requires that the
developer will work with the local
community
in terms of this proposal the land in
question is not currently protected by
any tree preservation order
nor is it designated as a wildlife site
it is however part of a wider area of
land warwickshire county council are
considering for a potential wildlife
site
but have not yet progressed the district
council is in discussion with them to
conduct the appropriate surveys
to establish the ecological value of the
site
since the pandemic struck the value of
the amenity of the woodlands for
residents of me and vale and beyond
has increased immensely since the
publication of the site allocation plan
proposals
there has been widespread and strong
feeling expressed
that the site should be preserved
entirely as woodland with enhanced
biodiversity
to create a green lung for the growing
myeonvale community
this is an entirely plausible potential
approach for the site that sees an
entirely different future for me and
vale woodland
so what we really need in order to
consider the best future for the site
is for as many of you as possible to let
us have your comments on the proposal
before you
and if you do not favor it what exactly
you would like to see the site look like
in future
together with any specific ideas that
you may have about what that looks like
i would reiterate that this is your
opportunity to have your say
and this council does listen and take
seriously the results of public
consultation in all its decision making
processes
so please do send in your comments and
thoughts on the site
details of how to respond to the
consultation can be found at our website
www.stratfor.gov
dot uk forward slash s-a-p-p-o
and the consultation runs until 5 pm on
the 18th of december 2020
i look forward to seeing your
representations
and thank you for your participation